[Music]
Teen Titans go is a cartoon comedy
version of the popular DC Universe
series Teen Titans but do you know the
show's darkest secrets wait until you
hear about the episode that got banned
because it was so inappropriate don't
forget to subscribe to the things and
give this video a big thumbs up now
let's check out 10 dark secrets about
Teen Titans go that Cartoon Network
doesn't want you to know rule breakers
let's start with the secret that gets
most hardcore fans really heated and as
we move on you'll see why some people
really really can't stand this show the
original DC Comics animated series seem
to have production limitations when it
came to crossing each other's world
since they all aired at the same time he
never really saw a Batman character in
Justice League Unlimited and you never
saw Teen Titans and Justice League
characters together everything seemed to
be produced in orderly fashion and
because it would just be weird to see
the same characters in another show at
the same time
but ever since Teen Titans went off air
series have crossed over worlds and one
of those series includes Teen Titans go
such rule breakers aren't they the
shared universe definitely has a unique
potential in Teen Titans go but it seems
that it wasn't so well received many
fans team to state that by breaking this
rule the Teen Titans go world failed to
be clearly defined this opened a lot of
plot holes and created some pretty
inconsistent character traits that
weren't really appealing to hardcore
fans they get it seems that the show
keeps on expanding its universe and
therefore breaking the original DC role
Jason Todd okay this one is just a
little bit morbid but it also connects
with the fact that this show has no
boundaries when it comes to going from
one universe to another you probably
never noticed this dark secret but if
you pay attention to Robins room you
might have spotted an Easter egg that's
way too much for a cartoon that's
supposed to be aimed at kids do you
remember Jason Todd the second Robin
from the main DC Comics unfortunately he
didn't really survive but what's even
more morbid is the fact that you can
find him in Robins room well at least
his ashes there on the shelf if Cartoon
Network really wanted you to pay more
attention to this they would have showed
it for more than just a millisecond
about a millisecond was
to make some fans pretty upset this
easter egg doesn't even make sense
considering Robin on the show is Dick
Grayson it seems strange that dick could
have returned to the Titans while still
a team because Jason Todd passed we told
you the inconsistencies and the way this
show mixes universes isn't exactly ideal
but hey party network doesn't want you
to pay attention to detail bad reviews
we bet there are a couple of hardcore
original Teen Titans fans that have I
rolled at this show way more than you
should have but for those that might not
know here's a fact this show has
absolutely terrible reviews and it's
mainly from people who expected it to be
some kind of continuation of the popular
DC comic world boy were they wrong the
show's been criticized for a lot of
things some of which will adjust in the
next couple of minutes parents seem to
have problems with the fact that the
show really isn't funny and one parent
wrote that it's disrespectful to the
original source material aka Teen Titans
another person also pointed out that
this show is just for casual fans and
it's definitely not made for those that
are way too into the DC comic world it's
also been criticized for not being
nearly enough positive or having enough
life lessons like some other shows on
Cartoon Network but despite the
criticism Teen Titans go season 5 was
announced in March 2018 the show is
still going strong so it almost feels
like Cartoon Network's completely
ignoring the feedback it gets from the
DC fandom but more about that later
inappropriate moments this show features
quite a few inappropriate moments and a
lot of them boiled down to a typical
Cartoon Network humor we have seen many
times before it seems like this show is
really trying hard to sneak in some
adult jokes for the parents but because
of the universe studying it doesn't
really translate well so for example in
an episode called lazy Sunday we see
Beast Boy and Cyborg being super lazy on
the couch but when some weird cloud of
smoke forms out of the couch it's a nod
to something kids shouldn't know about
and yes they also get the munchies when
you connect the laziness smoke and the
need for food it's very clear what this
show is implying but isn't that a bit
inappropriate and totally not normal for
this world considering something like
this was never really a thing in the
original world of course you can also
find Flynn
moments that are inappropriate because
they just don't fit in and because
they're just a little bit too focused on
adults Cartoon Network seems to really
struggle whether it wants to keep this
show in a kid's world or randomly bring
in some moments from the original Teen
Titans which is more aimed at adults
inappropriate jokes original Teen Titans
were no strangers to adult jokes for the
kids show has made those jokes even more
inappropriate for example and one of
Beast Boys songs that was about Raven he
sings how Raven doesn't know what to do
when she has to go to the bathroom no
we're not kidding it's an actual lyric
so the inappropriate jokes just got even
more childish this show includes butt
jokes and a lot of strange humor you
wouldn't expect from DC comic characters
and yet here we are
a lot of these jokes were very poorly
received but Cartoon Network continues
to ignore the feedback and of course
Cartoon Network embraces the adult humor
and just about every show they do but we
just can't get over these ones Beast Boy
drooling over Starfire and the spandex
was just a little bit over the top and
then there's this strange scene that we
don't really want to explain
seriously this show has way too many
dirty jokes and inappropriate moments
and it kind of takes away from what Teen
Titans really was about don't you think
Cartoon Network definitely wouldn't
agree with this statement though people
really hate this show seriously people
really dislike this show there are
plenty of reasons behind it but we'll
try to summarize them in the next couple
of seconds one of the main reasons why
people find this show so unappealing is
the fact that it came around the time
when a lot of DC Universe shows got
canceled including Young Justice many
expected to be excited at first about
the fact that Teen Titans go would serve
as a replacement only to be left totally
disappointed fans also seem to dislike
how this cartoon stereotypes the
characters that originally had quite
more layers backstories and flaws most
of those things get lost in Teen Titans
go as the show focuses far more on jokes
and keeping the kids attention
continuity has always been a constant
discussion in Teen Titans go fans seem
to have expected the show to be a direct
continuity of Teen Titans but it just
didn't turn out to be the case at all
in fact most of the episodes don't even
relate to one another so it all really
boiled
down to disappointment at the fact that
this version of Teen Titans was capped
while other original DC Universe series
that canceled there's going to be a
movie yep you heard that right there's
going to be a Teen Titans go movie okay
this is only a dark secret if you don't
really pay attention to this show that
much because you're one of those people
that really hate it
although Teen Titans go is a Cartoon
Network show it's being made by the
Warner Brothers Studio as of May 28 Teen
there hasn't really been that much buzz
around the movie just yet even though it
seems that the entire cast is chosen it
features some of the most popular and
relevant modern actors musicians and TV
personalities it includes Kristen Bell
palsy James Corden Nicolas Cage lil
yachty Jimmy Kimmel and even Tara Strong
who always has been the voice of Raven
according to some descriptions the movie
has an amusing take on superheroes so we
can imagine that if you don't like Teen
Titans go now you probably won't enjoy
this at all but we bet some of you are
excited as of right now the movies still
look pretty big and quite shocking
secret that will definitely Rock the
world of some hardcore DC fans so we'll
have to wait and see how this works out
Justice League problem we've already
mentioned that a lot of people dislike
Teen Titans go because it came out when
Cartoon Network very suddenly canceled
of Justice League cartoon network did
try to bring it back as Justice League
action in 2017 and the show had awesome
reviews but fans were pretty shocked
when they didn't notice the show in the
2017 Cartoon Network lineup and as of
May 2018 the season 2 of Justice League
action still hasn't been confirmed
despite the popular demand who knows
what's going through Cartoon Network's
head but we feel like they're definitely
keeping something away from us by
ignoring Justice League despite its
popularity on top of that 2017 was also
the year of the Justice League movie
rumor but it looks like the status of
the movie also got scrapped seriously
what is happening many fans are left
confused as to why Cartoon Network seems
to be totally biased to a single show
while ignoring everything else and if
you don't think that's true wait until
you hear about a secret many fans are
actually furious about and no one seems
to know the reason why it's happening
confusing marathons if you watch a lot
of Cartoon Network you probably know
is one of the most ridiculous things
ever it always seems to air Teen Titans
go it actually got to the point where a
lot of fans started to complain and set
up online petitions in order to fix that
seriously
we're not kidding the topic of why does
Cartoon Network air so much Teen Titans
go has been a constant debate with fans
with plenty of speculations it turns out
that this has been happening for the
past few years one of the fan theories
is that Teen Titans go is Cartoon
Network's few profitable shows because
it's cheaper to produce and they're
trying to make them most of it seriously
someone crunched some numbers and
realize that Cartoon Network aired
eighty four episodes of Teen Titans go
in a single week while other shows got
as little as five at some point the show
even aired 15 times a day
it seems that Cartoon Network's pulling
out some impressive marketing tricks in
order to make sure Teen Titans go is on
everybody's mind but it seems if their
trick is actually doing the opposite it
even went as far as airing specific
episodes multiple times a day
vans episode despite the fact that the
viewers don't really have a good
relationship with the show one of the
most darkest secrets of all times is
actually associated with sad world
events sometimes an episode of various
cartoon shows gets banned because it's
just inappropriate for the events that
are happening in the world at the moment
if anything this shows that not all
jokes are funny at all times that's
exactly what happened with Teen Titans
go around the time of the 2015 attacks
in Paris Teen Titans go wanted to air an
episode that focused on the team of
passing away of old age in the true
character stereotype Raven morbidly
confronts the so called executor in
order to save her friends while the plot
itself didn't really feature
inappropriate jokes like it usually does
Cartoon Network decided to pull the
episode in order to not insult the
victims by suggesting standing up to
something like this could save lives it
was a good move on Cartoon Network's
hard to actually pull the episode
however it's definitely a reminder that
the show should think twice before
trying to tackle just about any subjects
there is what do you think of Teen
Titans go love it hate it let us know in
the comments that's it for our video
thanks for watching
[Music]